[Music]
thank you for joining us my name is
Scott Lowenstein I'm a second year MBA
and a student leader for the
corporations and society initiative or
Kassie which is one of the co-sponsors
of the event today along with the Center
for Internet and Society and cs+ social
good Cassie is about bringing together
experts with business students and
policymakers to ask questions and being
a broader perspective of the role of
corporations and capitalism in society
today through research education
advocacy cassie is trying to redefine or
question some of the assumptions that
form the core of the role of private and
public institutions in our lives and
today we're talking about tech in many
ways the current crop of business school
students kind of grew up with platform
media I remember my sister showing me
the Facebook when it was a dot e-d-u
kind of place and I also remember in
2011 when Facebook was saving democracy
and and civil society around the world
and now we're an event called sucked so
the times have changed
but it's this kind of evolving facebook
conversation that's a perfect fit for
what Cassie is trying to do asking
questions like you know what does
Facebook Oh users share hold there's
society at large is internet addiction
and fake news the inevitable output of
sort of shareholder value maximization
model in the internet age and how do we
kind of tame or tamp down some of this
what Tristan Harris calls runaway
attention maximizing technology so it's
these questions and many more that Roger
McNamee addresses in his book sucked
waking up to the Facebook catastrophe
Roger has 35 years of investing
experience in Silicon Valley he was an
early advisor to Mark Zuckerberg his
most recent fund elevation was
co-founded by YouTube's bond
and when he's not on book tour he's
rocking out with his band moon Alice I
can't wait to hear about Roger sort of
personal transformation from face book
champion to a whistleblower of sorts
about the dangers of the platform I mean
in moderating that conversation is Anne
Grimes and is an award-winning
journalist two held senior editorial
positions at The Washington Post and The
Wall Street Journal she ran Stanford's
gradualism program she now is the
co-director of the Brown Institute for
Media innovation in the engineering
department and she's taught all over the
school in CS and engineering at the
d.school
and here at the Business School in a
class on media entrepreneurship which is
where I first heard Roger talk about
some of these ideas last year following
their conversation we'll have some
questions from students in the audience
but now please join me in thanking and
welcoming Ann and Roger hi welcome it's
great to see such a big crowd here at
your lunch hour so thanks everybody for
showing up and thank you Roger
no my pleasure let me start off by
saying that Roger and I have known each
other for a while now since my days at
the Wall Street Journal when I was
covering venture capital and I thought
of him as just another venture
capitalist but you know look at you now
you're a you've written a really
thoughtful readable well scripted book
it's a best-seller it's a great read
you're killing it
congratulations and you're you're
scaring me not just because you're sort
of moving in on my writing turf here
because but because what you're you're
you're telling us all is that it looks
like we are all really sucked
so before me before we start how many
folks have read Rogers book or have
bought Roger's book thank you thank you
all right there are there were books
will be on sale out in the vestibule so
don't be don't be shy with your wallets
so let me let me say a little bit about
the book before we start our
conversation the tone of the book is
really interesting it's a manifesto of
sorts it's a call of a call to action
and it the tone is very thoughtful in
the book
Roger starts by saying that he is an
investor he was an early investor in
Facebook and he still has his investment
in Facebook but that he learned that his
father he felt his trust in Facebook was
misplaced
and this is largely a story about trust
you say that even though Facebook
provides a compelling experience for
most users it is terrible for America it
needs to be changed
you described Facebook as a threat
technology like Facebook's you say
allows it to manipulate our attention
the design of Facebook allows bad actors
to exploit it and harm innocent people
democracy has been undermined because of
design choices and business decisions by
Internet platforms not just Facebook but
many others that deny responsibility for
the consequences of their actions the
culture of these companies causes
employees to be indifferent to the
negative side effects of their success
you say these platforms have taken
advantage of our trust and you say you
have had a conversion experience
this sounds like tough love to me
and there's a lot to unpack there so but
before we do that let's start a little
bit with the back story here tell us a
bit more about your background and how
you got involved with Facebook in the
first place how many of you were at GSB
just for last to see okay
so here's the thing they don't tell you
this in business school I mean he
certainly didn't tell me if he can
literally what you really need to have a
successful career he's just incredible
good luck I started my career in the
first day of the bull market of 1982
they assigned me to technology I mean I
wanted to do tech but they let me do
tech and this is in the days when the
space shuttle was the biggest thing
going on in Silicon Valley and the tech
industry so men I had for the entirety
of my career a gale-force tailwind I
literally couldn't miss and you know
they tell you in Modern Portfolio theory
that on average active managers can't
beat the market what they don't tell you
is they're 200 million or 300 million
participants in the market so
statistically they're gonna be tens of
thousands of people who outperform in
the market by two standard deviations
for their entire career on the basis of
pure dumb luck and I want you understand
I'm one of them okay so when I met Mark
Zuckerberg in 2006 he had just turned 22
and I had just turned 50 I've been
investing half of my life
and I got asked by one of marks
colleagues would I take a meeting with
his boss because there was a crisis and
he need to talk to somebody on the
outside no other information provided
the thing to understand in 2006 there
were a few things going on in Silicon
Valley that were really worth paying
attention to
the PayPal mafia Peter Thiel and Elon
Musk and and Reid Hoffman in that gang
it had two unbelievably powerful
insights the first was that the internet
was shifting from a web of pages to a
web of people and that the limitations
on technology that had constrained
everybody around here for the prior
50 years that it made us focus on the
narrowest most important functionality
that people need at any point in time
those were going away and you're for the
first time gonna be able to create
global products you were gonna be able
to crepe services like Amazon Web
Services that would allow entrepreneurs
to buy the hundred million or two
hundred million dollars worth of
infrastructure that previously you had
to build just to launch your product
which meant the cost of a startup was
going to go from a hundred million to 10
million it meant instead of needing 45
to 50 year old entrepreneurs you could
do it with 20 year olds so when Mark
started Facebook he literally started it
at the perfect moment in time and I was
absolutely convinced even in 2006 when
it was just available to high school and
college students with their school
address when it was just a facebook
picture address and relationship status
that he was going to be bigger than
Google and I was convinced to that
because I had watched myspace Friendster
and and America online all failed in
their social activity because in my
opinion anonymity allowed trolls and bad
actors to overwhelm the platforms so I
was really excited to meet mark and the
first day we met he comes into my office
and you know it's six months after the
end of the timeline of the social
network movie and he looks just like
Mark Zuckerberg
he's got the sandals he's got to tight
the skinny jeans got the t-shirt the
hoodie courier bag he sits down I sit
down I'm closer to him than I am to Ann
right now we're in these comfy chairs in
this conference room at elevation and I
said mark before you say a word I got to
give you some context for why I took
this meeting and I said look if it
hasn't already happened either Google I
saw either Microsoft or Yahoo is gonna
offer 1 billion dollars for your company
and everybody you know your parents your
board of directors your management team
employees friends everybody can take
mark you got no revenue take the money
it's a billion dollars you'll have six
hundred million six hundred fifty
million bucks and we'll be rich take the
money your venture capitalist Jim Breyer
he's going to
he'll back your next company I said mark
you need to know there's two things I
know for sure after 24 years is
investing one is no entrepreneur in the
history of Silicon Valley ever had the
perfect idea at the perfect time twice
nobody not Steve Jobs not anybody and
I'm convinced you've got the perfect
idea at the perfect time you're gonna be
bigger than Google secondly I don't care
who buys us company they're gonna kill
it if you believe this idea the only way
to make it happen is for you to take it
out what followed that was the most
painful five minutes of my entire life
mark didn't see it worried he was
thinking really hard did he trust me did
he not trust me in the end he relaxes
and he goes you won't believe this but
that's the reason I'm here that story
you just told that just happened exactly
as you said how did you know and I go I
didn't know I just know all the people
around here have been around here a long
time and this is how things work around
here what do you want to do and he said
well what am I gonna do everybody who
wants to sell the business but me I
can't run it by myself and I said hang
on dude you got plenty of money you get
a great idea it's really working they
don't get to tell you the music what's
the song it's over
let me explain to you how to walk them
off the cliff and so he went back and
the whole meeting took less than half an
hour he went back and he told everybody
and I think in retrospect they're all
pretty happy that he talked them out of
selling a company so he had this problem
right that everybody'd wanted to sell
the company so it was helpful to have a
new advisor who believed in his vision
so for a period of three years I got to
be one of many advisors that he had and
the principal thing I do was help to
bring cherylin and I'd known Cheryl
because she introduced me to bono and
I'd helped to introduce her to Google
and so you can imagine I was just so
proud of Facebook I thought mark was
different I thought the culture of the
valley at the time which was this you
know it was replacing the hippie
libertarianism of Steve Jobs that notion
of empowering people with a different
kind of libertarianism that was really
more by building monopoly
you know disrupting and dominating you
know that that you didn't really worry
about what the rules were he just kind
of went and did things he didn't ask
permission you beg forgiveness that
culture was very uncomfortable for me
and in the early days I think Mark had a
different view or at least that's what I
thought he had and so I was blissfully a
fan I mean just a huge fan and I got to
the end of my career and I'd retired
before I realized there was something
wrong not to say that there weren't
signals there were signals and it's an
analyst I should have put them together
better than I did but I didn't and I
feel bad about that so how did you move
from an advisor to skeptic were there
key points to be clear there was a
middle point in the way where I was just
a fan right where you know I was not
regularly interacting with either mark
or show and you know I stopped being an
insider in 2009 because you know the
things I was really good at he didn't
need anymore and so I'm just in a
cheerleader and then I retire in
December of 2015 and in January I start
to see things that don't fit my
preconceived notion of this company I
loved and these people I loved first it
was in the Democratic primary in New
Hampshire I start to see memes coming
out of Facebook groups that are
associated not notionally with the
Bernie Sanders campaign but they were
spreading virally among my friend group
in a way that suggested somebody was
spending money to get people into a
group whose only purpose was to spread
misogynistic memes that struck me is
really weird
then two months later Facebook expelled
a company that was using the ad tools to
gather data on people who expressed an
interest in black lives matter and they
were selling that data to police
departments now Facebook did the right
thing right they expelled them the
problem was the damage had been done
police departments were harassing these
people then in June of 2016 the United
Kingdom votes on the brexit referendum
to leave the European Union and you may
know the outcome was a huge shock
eight-point swing during the day of the
referendum
and it occurred to me that Wow what if
the Facebook tools that allow you know
ideas to spread so rapidly what if if
there's something about them that gives
an unfair advantage to really intense
nasty messages over at neutral ones
because the the leave campaign had this
intense xenophobic message and the
remain campaign was kind of hey stay the
course and I'm sitting there going wow
if that's true that's like really bad
for democracy but I don't know I have no
data so I start going to look for
friends to say is anybody seeing this
and he actually reached out to Facebook
too but I didn't know what I was seeing
so it was really hard to connect with
anyone I mean connect with them in the
sense of convey what my concerns were we
then find out about manna fort in August
and around Labor Day Walt Mossberg asked
me you know from recode what Mossberg
asked me are writing up in which I start
drafting but I'm not in any huge hurry
because it doesn't even occur to me that
the US election could be in danger again
real failure finale analysis I guess I
was retired and anyway long story short
two things happen first Housing and
Urban Development Department of the US
government sites Facebook for
advertising tools that enable
discrimination housing the very thing
they were sued over a few weeks ago but
that was the first salvo of it and then
the intelligence agencies say the
Russians are actively interfering in the
u.s. election at that point I freaked
out I realize I'm not going to do an
op-ed I got to reach out to market share
they're my friends I'm a huge believer
in this company and so on the 30th of
October nine days before the election I
send them the draft op-ed and say guys I
think there is something wrong with the
business model and algorithms that's
allowing bad actors to harm innocent
people and we got to get on top of it
now in retrospect I wish I hadn't sent
them the op-ed I wish I'd rewritten it
because the op-ed is you know it's
designed to be provocative and it would
have been better if I'd been a little
bit more level but they got right back
to me and there couldn't have been more
friendly but they didn't embrace it like
was a real business issue they treated
like a PR problem and they handed me off
to Dan Rose who was a real good friend
of mine so I was actually totally
psyched to talk to him
but Dan's job was to essentially contain
the PR problem and he goes Roger we do
not have a problem here section 230 of
the Communications Decency Act says
we're a platform not a media company so
we're not responsible for what third
party still and I go din you got civil
rights problems and you get some weird
stuff in democracy you think people are
gonna let you off the hook for that he
goes yeah we don't have a problem anyway
the election happens at that point I go
completely ballistic I go Dan you have
got to get honest you have got to do
what Johnson & Johnson did when some
put poison and bottles of
Tylenol in Chicago in 1982 the CEO of
Johnson Johnson the very day the story
happened pulled every bottle of Tylenol
off every retail shelf in the United
States and Canada no questions asked and
didn't put them back till they invented
tamper proof packaging I said Dan you
have to leave to the defense the people
who use your product you cannot have the
uncertainty you are in a trust business
if you let the trust get broken
you will never earn it back I spent
three months begging him to do this and
he's just hiding behind section 230 and
I go eventually I give up and it's at
that point that I faced a moment of
truth that maybe one or more of you will
face at some point in your life I saw
something really wrong something with
issues that I could see already for
democracy and issues for civil rights I
was retired I could have sat back and
just said this is somebody else's
problem but the other side of the coin
was I'd been a small part of this and
I'd profited from it and I felt a moral
and emotional need to take what I knew
to take my biography and try to start a
conversation about what had happened I
was really our decision
so as part of your journey from a from
an investor to a skeptic to a to an
activist it it struck me in reading that
your story that you think Facebook is
essentially a closed system and that the
leaders are not willing to engage in
sort of this big picture thinking we've
seen we've seen them go on the sort of
apology tour over and over and over
again and I wonder when it's worked
really well right move fast break things
apologize repeat okay
all right some might say that but but
when did you realize that that they were
this isn't fair - am i describing this
correctly do you think they are a close
it's a closed the closed culture there -
me either had Stata - your doubts to me
that's not the answer is yes but I
that's not the operative thing I mean
Facebook exists in a culture here in the
valley which in turn exists in the
culture in the United States of America
well we have deregulated for 44 years we
have essentially gone from a version of
capitalism of a standard version where
the government sets the rules and
enforces them across the entire economy
so that's fair for everyone to a world
with essentially very few rules and
almost no enforcement where businesses
are encouraged to grab whatever they can
grab while they can grab it and we've
gone from this world that Peter Drucker
who was a great management guru of the
Industrial Age back when I was young he
would say there are five stakeholders
right shareholders employees the
communities where employees live
customers and suppliers and that it was
the duty of management to balance the
interests of all five because that's how
you maintain it was a zen-like harmony
that you would maintain over time but
over the last 40 years we've abandoned
four of the five and essentially all
companies in the economy abused their
suppliers they many of them abuse their
customers they couldn't care less about
the communities where people live and
many of them have treated their
employees badly
and so I look at this and by the way if
that has been standard operating
procedure right now if Rex Tillerson is
allowed to conduct a separate foreign
policy at Exxon in contravention of our
sanctions against Russia if Wells Fargo
Bank can get away with essentially
defrauding millions of account holders
if the entire banking industry can do
2008 not be punished it's really hard to
expect Silicon Valley to have a higher
set of standards than that and so to me
that was a big part of the problem was
that you know it's these are not bad
people right that's the key thing I
don't think the managers are bad I don't
think the people are bad who work there
I think the issue is the culture is just
way off track we kept doing the same
thing over and over again and we forget
that there's natural pendulum in society
to keep things in balance and we're just
out of balance and so when I look at
Facebook let's face it that company was
so successful for so long you can't
blame them for thinking if critic then
wrong right I mean I'm sure they looked
at me and said Roger if you're so smart
where you're two and a half billion
users right I get that that's just how
the world was okay the incentives are
misaligned and it's way bigger than
Facebook way bigger than Silicon Valley
and demonstrable you know you can see
that there's a beginning of a change
right we've had at least five teacher
actions labor actions in the last year
all successful first successful teacher
labor actions I think in a generation
the air traffic controllers with a
partial sick-out ended a government
shutdown in two hours and McDonald's has
abandoned the fight against 15 those are
all incredibly important indicators that
we just may have reached the furthest
limit of this penciler swinging that
we're gonna begin to swing back so I'm
extremely optimistic about that and
again I don't think I'd look at Facebook
and I think their behavior even now look
mark I give mark a lot of credit cuz
he's coming out and talking in public
now
and I think what he's saying is nonsense
but his PR department creates
right and they do what their job is
right which is to create nonsense to
distract I get that
right I mean I have been around a long
time it's like this is how it works I'm
not gonna hold them to a higher standard
and everybody else but I want to hold
everybody to a higher standard than
we've held them to for the last few
years okay well let me just drill down a
little bit on this because in in the in
the book on the character issue and
culture ashley issue you say mark
zuckerberg created a culture in which
criticism and disagreement apparently
had no place yeah you say you say you
didn't realize that Mark Zuckerberg
ambition had no limit you say that
Facebook secret sauce is its ability to
imitate and improve on ideas of others
and scale them what I'm saying is I was
a terrible analyst for a number of years
okay that's really a conclusion all of
that was obvious to anybody covering the
company so can I take a minute because I
want to talk about what I think the real
problem is here because I think Facebook
is by no me Facebook is the biggest
problem we have for democracy but if you
sit there and you think about therefore
clouds as a problem their public health
issues there's democracy issues there's
privacy issues and then there's the
whole structure of the economy and I
want to dial it back to 2002 and I want
to look at would be incredible genius of
Google and what they did in 2002 Google
behaves just like a classic marker they
have one product it's a search engine
they gathered data from the people who
use it to make that product better
completely normal natural thing to do
the business model is based on IDI
targeting related to purchase intent
right you want to go on vacation you
look up places to go you look a bear
lines you look up hotels the whole nine
yards right they do the analysis they
discover they only need a few percent of
the data in order to make the engine
better so they look at and go well is
there any signal and the rest in the
other 97 98 percent and they not only
discover a signal but it's for something
much bigger than purchase intent its
behavioral prediction the big enchilada
but they look at me go holy we got
this problem we don't even know who
these people are so they create Gmail
now Gmail gives my identity to attach to
purchase intent that makes the ads
wildly more valuable right makes the
targeting better so the consumer has a
better experience so far everybody's
fine but then this is where the culture
of the valley the culture of America
takes over they realize well they can do
way better if you're gonna be in the
behavioral prediction market what is the
single best source of intelligence for
behavioral prediction it's people's
emails you tell people what you're gonna
do so they got to find an excuse for
reading the emails see business model
will give it away for free well put ads
in it well tell me gotta scan the emails
or to target the end to hate the ads but
will at least get the skinny emails so
they gave us duck food in the form of
ads
we got pissed we forced them to get rid
of the ads but they continue to scan the
emails you see yourself well is that
okay remember they've told us they're
not a media company they're a platform
which means they're a common carrier
Postal Service read your mail they go to
jail Federal Express reach your docks
they go to jail common carriers are not
allowed to read the content that stuff
going through and remember what consent
is consent in common law requires both
sides to have the same understanding
demonstrable not true here so that
however is a genius way if you want to
get into behavioral prediction and there
are new rules right nobody's got a
problem so they move on they go to maps
find out where everybody is so it Maps
they gather all this data create this
incredibly convenient set of services
the next thing you know they can predict
what you're gonna do right but their
problem here is they need to understand
the routes and everything that's going
on so they've run some behavioral
manipulation experiments right this
route over here but not enough people
take it we don't know how long it takes
so we're gonna give it to you and tell
you that's the suggested route this
morning we're gonna see if we can get
you to take it and of course we did
right we've all had that experience you
get in ways now all the time right think
idiots think oh it's only gonna take 23
minutes 37 minutes later you're pulling
up where you're going
right so now they're in the behavioral
manipulation business and that's not
what we signed up for that's when they
have the genius insight there's all this
unclaimed data in the economy and the
economy is incredibly inefficient
because there's all this uncertainty but
if we get all this data we can take the
uncertainty out of it so they start
driving cars up down the street they
call Street View the Germans go wait a
minute that's my house that's my kid
that's my dog you can't do that that's
what the Stasi is to do everybody else
goes and no problem then they do
satellite view right so if you're in the
breaking-and-entering business you've
now got street view and satellite view
and then they tried Google glass
remember that now they're going around
and they're getting real-time the other
two things are static but this is
real-time and lots of facial recognition
lots of individual walking routes
driving routes all kinds of cool stuff
but we hate it right we called them
glass holes right remember that so they
go back into the laps they repackage it
as a video game they spin it out as a
separate company called Niantic they
called it pokemons go they got 1 billion
people wandering around with their
smartphones taking pictures of
everything
now the behavioral manipulation gets
really interesting if we put a Pokemon
in private property well people climb
over a fence yeah it turns out they
would if we put a pokey bond in a
Starbucks can we get you to go in to buy
some coffee you bet
how about if we do it in the third
Starbucks and give you 10 cents off and
see whether you'll go a little further
yeah you'll do that too really largest
behavioral manipulation experiment ever
run outside of China really really
successful and we're in a different
world down right our whole thing is we
love these apps but we think what we're
getting is better targeting but what's
really going on is large-scale
behavioral manipulation where it's not
our data causing that it's everybody
else's data then what happens then they
go wait a minute but there's all this
data that other people own let's go and
buy it so they go to your bank they go
to data logics they go to
Experian and Equifax they buy all your
financial data they go to the cellular
carriers get all your location data
they've already got the data from uber
and lyft they go to health and wellness
apps and they get all that stuff they do
all this tracking they scan your
documents they've built a data avatar of
each and every one was whether you're on
the platform or not and the problem is
only 1% of the value is in the stuff you
put in postive it's the metadata that
tracking you know the buy of the
browsing history and the stuff they
acquire and then we're in the world of
certainty right because what they're
selling to the advertiser is that so
think about this anybody here been seen
Google CAPTCHA right they say are you a
robot tell me look at these pictures of
cars or street signs or whatever right
you know what's going on right you're
training the self-driving cars right
google's AI for self-driving cars right
that's why they never show you things of
livestock I want the ones that tell you
the difference between a pig and an
elephant right that's what I'm waiting
for but no you're training the AI for
self doubt they know you're a human
because the way your mouth moves and
they save everything so I assume for me
they have this long profile of my mouse
movement here's the thing some day I'm
likely to develop Parkinson's disease
now what app is likely to see the very
first symptom of Parkinson's disease an
app that's measuring the movement of my
mouse and here's what's wrong with the
model I'm not their customer
I'm not even their product I'm the fuel
for this data avatar I'm a source of
data they're under no obligation to tell
me that I have a potential medical
diagnosis they're under no obligation to
protect my privacy and all the financial
centers just sell that certainty to the
highest bidder and who will value at the
most my insurance company who will
either raise my rates or cut off my
insurance and I won't even know I'm sick
because if they tell me then it's a
pre-existing condition those are
terrible incentives
so my basic point you is what's happened
here and Google perfected this
but now Facebook Amazon and Microsoft
are playing this game also there's all
this data in the economy all the state
in society and with it you can take
uncertainty out of life but here's the
thing to think about when you wake up in
the morning right you have free will you
have the ability to choose are you gonna
go to work today not go to work today
eat breakfast don't eat breakfast
exercise don't exercise but if
everything in life is certain what
happens to free will in an economic
sense what happens to choice that's the
question that we have to ask today and
what I've discovered is that when I go
around and I do this thing it doesn't
matter what the politics are other
people I talk to they go huh that
doesn't sound right
that sounds like China and I go that's
cuz it is China right when Google says
you can't regulate us cuz we have to
compete with China ai I go oh oh I
didn't want to do that why do we want to
be competing with China and behavioral
modification that'd be like saying we
want to compete with them and clothing
babies or time-release anthrax right we
got better things to do ai is the
penicillin of the 21st century let's
apply it to things that make our lives
better so
let's see here
behavioral predictions that's the root
of all of it you also talked about the
addictions that this technology the
addictions think of this and and they
and the anonymity and yeah creating
tribes and polarization so you said what
you say in your book and the two biggest
things you outline there are the threats
to in addition to what you've just said
public health with our addiction to our
phones and technology as well as the
threats to our democracy system Roger
how do I so my question my question is
is at the root of this what's the the
key design problem here yeah that you
that you would like to see solved to fix
all this so here's what the problem is
if you're in the behavioral prediction
business you do not want to be stuck
with the data related to our public
selves right because we're all on our
best behavior here right if you want to
find out what people are really about
you've got to get the act of pierce the
shell of civility around each one of us
and the best way to do that right is to
provoke us right so if you think about
what engagement is right if your problem
here is that you want to build a habit
and then with the habit you want to then
feed the habit with things and engage
people right and it turns out that
people are most engaged by stuff the
other triggers flight-or-fight which
would be outrage or fear or really
conspiracy theories or disinformation
and nobody really knows why this
information is so successful but it is
and so essentially what this is about
is you want to get people into an
unstable state to find out what they're
really like I mean what happens when you
expose them to anti-semitism how do they
react what happens when you expose them
to hate speech what happens when you
expose them to the threat of some you
let's say you know me
without break right the problem with the
business model is that you know it
depends on hate speech fear outrage
disinformation and conspiracy theories
those are the things that bring out what
they need for behavioral prediction
those are not the things they need for
great ad targeting right this is what
you need if you want to eventually go to
behavioral manipulation and so my point
here is that when I look at GD P R when
I look at the California private's law I
see things that are fail in two ways
they fail because first of all they only
address 1% of the problem they don't
address metadata they don't address
browser history and they don't address
the data acquire from third parties
which is where most of the value is but
secondly they happen after the fact if
you want to solve the problem you have
to take away the incentive to have
inappropriate stuff there in the first
place I don't want to be in the
censoring business I want to be in the
business of eliminating the
amplification of the worst the content
that essentially creates political
polarization and creates all these
unhealthy out outcomes and so I think
the way to do that is to ask the first
step is to ask political questions why
is it legal for somebody to scan your
email or your documents why is it legal
for there to be a third party commerce
in your most intimate personal data why
is it even legitimate to capture data on
children at all that's the debate we
need to have in 2020 and that's the
debate that interestingly enough brings
people together because it doesn't
matter where there are left or right
this is an issue of right or wrong not
right or left and what I've found in the
ten weeks so far of my book tour is it
doesn't matter whether on fox or MSNBC
Fox Business CNBC conservative talk
radio NPR everybody goes wait a minute
you're right why is any of that stuff
legal because if you could take that
away then we would go back to a model
that wasn't
on the bad stuff bad stuff would still
happen but it wouldn't be part of the
design and again this is really
important I'm not suggesting that any of
these people are bad people or they did
this on purpose these are the unintended
consequences of a well intended strategy
where the well intended strategy was to
connect the whole world in Facebook's
case or to expose all the world's
information in Google's case the problem
was they failed they were in such a
hurry they failed to put in circuit
breakers they failed to think about
containment strategies because that was
the culture at the time I get it
this is just like the chemical industry
thirty years ago you know chemical
companies used to be able to pour
mercury into fresh water right they left
mind tailings on the side of the hill
right if you're a gas station you poured
you used oil into the sewer and for like
50 years nobody said anything but then
the externality started to pile up and
people went wait a minute this is no
good and they went back to the guys who
created the problem said hey toxic oil
spill toxic chemical spill your problem
you clean it up I think we're looking at
toxic digital spills that's all no
seriously this isn't about people this
is about hey look we had a business kick
we had a business culture for a long
time I just think it's time to change
the culture and the reason I want to use
antitrust laws because I want to have I
believe all problems create a much
bigger business opportunity in the form
of when you make the solution that the
really simple thing here is you know
these guys aren't going to go away
you're just gonna create this huge new
industry in the history of tech is that
starting in 56 with AT&T with the
consent decree first we created the
computer industry
we got the transistor at ATT and created
all Silicon Valley right then IBM you
created the software business and PCs
then the second 18t you accelerate
cellular phones and you create broadband
data which creates the commercial
Internet and then Microsoft you create
the second wave Internet I mean and
every time the target company goes to
all-time highs the big complaint about
those things was she didn't actually get
rid of the monopolies you just created a
whole new industry I'm going what hang
on I'm ok with that
but you got to stop them from blocking
everything so we use the antitrust thing
that we used on ATT long-distance right
which was we created MCI and sprint by
giving them access and really
extraordinarily low rates to the long
distance line well in this case what
you're gonna do is very simple
any new startup that has a business
model that fits the pattern we're
looking for which is se not exploitable
people gets free access to advertising
for customer acquisition on the big
platforms and let's just say it's free
up to a hundred million people we could
pick the number but just think about
that for a minute what would that do for
innovation
how many startups you think we'd have if
it was free for the first hundred
million people how would that change the
cost of doing a start-up right cuz the
problem you got right now is that
Facebook Google Amazon Microsoft they've
got like 80% of all the AI people in
North America and they're all working on
behavioral modification so if you want
to do something else you got to compete
with that how's that work you know the
control they provide they have these
marketplaces where they provide perfect
information on one side right Faustian
bargain because there's no brand value
right everybody gets the same perfect
information but the guys on the other
side the consumers they only get the
data that Google and Facebook give them
right so once they figure out your
economics the prices you see the options
you see are tailored to what they know
about you because they're removing
uncertainty again I'm a big believer in
choice I'm a believer in capitalism I'd
like to get back to it okay we're gonna
take a couple questions let me ask one
more and the the microphone is let me
let me just ask one more and then we'll
turn to you and then if we could I'd
love at least one or two women to come
over here and ask okay so we've talked
about now it sounds like you feel like
there's some momentum you and tristin
Harris your
your colleague have gained some momentum
in capturing the attention of the public
of legislators in California as well as
in Washington DC and this debate and
this conversation is becoming national
so I don't give us credit I actually
give journalists much more credit than I
give ourselves because today hardly a
day goes by without another story about
something really important going we like
to hear that we've talked and then in
terms of solutions we've talked a little
bit about technical fixes we've talked I
think we'd like to hear what you think
we personally yeah what can do and
next-generation companies go ahead right
I want somebody to make a mouse product
that tells me if I've got the first
symptom of Parkinson's disease right
it's an insurance product just think
about every single thing that happens on
the Internet today reverse the polarity
of the business model instead of
treating the consumers the fuel treat
them as the customer what does that
business model look like it's not gonna
create things of the scale of Google on
Facebook but it is gonna create a
thousand companies with a billion dollar
market cap okay and that should be
enough right I mean I think that's
that's a cool thing if you get to save
democracy and you get to save public
health and you get to save privacy and
you get to save the economy right and I
may be wrong but let's have that
conversation let's have it right here
right because I mean this is where so
many good ideas originate there's a
question of how and when and if the
regulator's can jump in and will they be
effective you've you've you've suggested
banning BOTS stopping acquisitions there
will transparent about political ads and
algorithms none of that none of the
stuff that has happened so far addresses
the underlying problems what we're
really trying to do is to restart a
regulatory infrastructure that's been
more been for 25 years and that's really
hard right I mean the FTC and the
Antitrust Division of Justice have done
nothing that was related to consumer
for since the Microsoft case and I'm
working with both of them and it's it's
a little bit slow going
but I have the economics and law school
economics department law school of
another university that have found a way
to use Chicago School antitrust against
these platforms and that the model is
very straightforward we've always said
the services are free but that's
actually not correct it's a it's a
barter of services for personal data the
data is the currency and what happens
it's really obvious when you look at
either Facebook or Google that the price
in data has been rising geometrically I
mean well let's just say it's been
rising in a very steep slope okay
and you get the marker for that is
simply average revenue per user though
the suite of services really hasn't been
changing much and the individual value
of an action on any service doesn't
change much and yet the value of the
data being given up is going up very
significantly and so that model we have
the a Nobel Prize was awarded last year
for a similar analysis relative to
carbon credits and so they're literally
they're probably people in the econ
Department here working on things like
this and I would invite those people to
reach out to me because I think it's
really straightforward and so working
with justice and and and FTC on that
working with some state AG's the
Europeans got a huge running start but
they got a running start before we
understood the full scope of the problem
so the things they've done you know are
too narrow and the thing in the UK and
the thing and the thing in Australia is
nuts
okay the thing in the UK is maybe nuts
maybe not here it wouldn't work there it
may but what's going on as government's
are fed up and they're fed up because
facebook says the same thing over and
over again expecting a different
response and Google says we're not
involved and they're furious and so
they're doing dumb stuff they're getting
ever bigger mallets right and we've got
to get serious about this right
otherwise real harm is gonna get done
that you
can't fix and I think New Zealand
changes a lot of things politically
because New Zealand is really a theater
piece right that terrorists took the
architecture of the internet so the
ability of malcontented people to find
each other and connect to act
anonymously in their own interest and
then they exploited the architecture of
every social media platform right both
in advance and after the fact to amass a
group spread the toxic stuff and then
amplify it and the problem here isn't
just that it took seven to ten minutes
for Facebook to even notice there was a
problem and like an hour before they did
anything about it the problem was if it
had taken one second it would have
already been too late and there is no
circuit breaker I suspect at least one
country in this calendar year will
mandate that they have a button that can
shut down any internet service during a
problem that occurred that demonstrably
shutting down YouTube would have been
extremely helpful at limiting the spread
of this and potentially changing the
incentives right it may be enough for a
terrorist just to shut down YouTube
right so we have to think all that stuff
through but really harsh stuff is coming
and you know because the thing with New
Zealand worked so well and there's
nothing out there to prevent it from
happening again
one last question how about the role of
investors in all of this well you still
own stock in Facebook I do if you think
it is such a catastrophe is the word in
the title of your book why are you still
allowing your money to remain in
Facebook so instead of another the money
in Facebook is very simple I didn't want
anyone to accuse me of speaking ill of a
company whose stock I had just
my theory was I've made a lot of money
in this stock and if my actions were
gonna cause it to go down I was gonna
share that with everyone else that's a
personal value judgment you can agree or
disagree I think investors have a huge
role to play it is time to get off the
nonsense of just focusing on shareholder
value it's time to start looking at
society it's starting to start looking
at employees communities where they live
customers and suppliers again and you
know I'm not gonna win that argument by
myself but we have to stop looking at
big data the way we're looking at it
we've got to start thinking about
inverting the polarity and exposing that
data to make consumers lives more
successful we've got to stop viewing
people as a source of fuel it's really
bad and nothing is worth it right if we
can't see that then we need to read more
books we need to meet more people we
need to actually visit with the people
who've been harmed because remember you
didn't need to be on Facebook to be dead
in Myanmar we just needed to be a row
hinga you didn't need to be on any of
these platforms to be dead in New
Zealand you just need to be a Muslim and
one of those mosques you didn't need to
be on a platform to have your business
destroyed me United Kingdom you just
need to be EU centric right this is not
small stuff these are people's lives now
we've lost sight of that
and again I may be the wrong messenger
for you but think about the message find
someone who is because we can do better
we really can't okay okay we're gonna
take some questions and our first
question is going to come from Carlos
Gomez Uribe who has worked on algorithms
at Netflix Google and most recently
Facebook he has been a more recent
insider in Facebook than you have Roger
so thank you more than a question I
mostly have a comment
it is quite refreshing to hear your
perspective I think it's important and
I'd love to see more discussions of this
kind and I also want to state with the
obvious which is the thing where you
ended which is that many of these
algorithms can actually be quite helpful
at improving how we make decisions exact
I worked on search at Google first for
two years I was eating ball over seven
years at Netflix so I know how both all
the recommendations there and the search
words inside and out
I invented a bunch of those that are
running in production and because like
you I grew increasingly concerned with a
role of Facebook in helping us
understand their collective reality and
then making decisions for example in the
ballads I reached out and I offered to
join them doing what I know how to do
which is to build algorithms and I
joined them for a year and a half as a
director supposedly in charge of what
they call integrity for news feed doctor
terminology that includes hate speech
includes misinformation and so on and
before going there before going to
Facebook he was super interested in
being able to make a positive difference
in you know diminishing these problems I
expected them to be the hardest
technical problems I had seen just
because you know they reflect
essentially all of human complexity and
I assume that Facebook having all the
smart people that I knew they have must
have tried all the obvious things one
should try to make algorithms that are
high quality meaning that create
incentives for higher quality content
and for higher quality interactions and
I left her after a year and a half
because like you I completely lost trust
not only in mark and Sheryl but in at
least three three layers of leadership
at Facebook one of the things that's
interesting about this problem is
remember they've eliminated pornography
right I mean they're plenty smart enough
if they want to get rid of a lot of the
stuff right yeah they could make it a
lot less the problem is
they need something that activates the
lizard brain to find out what we're
really like right well Jason no I think
in the case of Facebook yes did it
and maybe more generally when you're
thinking about the business model that's
that relies on advertising where again
the users of their products are the
product themselves well so one point is
that I don't think that is true all
Internet companies okay that means
Netflix exactly can I say sir because I
want to point to Netflix it's a really
interesting thing because Netflix
obviously has the ability to do harm if
it want to do but Damali is not doing so
right at least that's the way it looks
to me and I look at Apple they could do
a lot of harm and they're clearly trying
not to right I mean there are plenty of
existence proofs of this being done but
also you know having people with with
morals with ethics people who care about
the world and everything dividuals at
the top and who aren't who are willing
to spend the time that's necessary to
understand how their products their
platform actually works and who are very
thoughtful about it that is not the way
things are on Facebook unfortunately but
I think you also pointed with the
business model is the problem
it's peer to the problem yes it's a big
part I mean it helps a lot to be Apple
to be Netflix and have built a model
where the consumer is your customer so
the last point I want to make and I'm
happy to help take any questions or
thoughts and specifically if I'm gonna
sign books afterwards outside so anybody
else who has questions I'll be outside
for a while yeah sounds good we have
time for just a few more
okay so last comment quick comment you
know the people in these rooms whether
it's Google Facebook Netflix making
decisions about these products that end
up affecting pretty much the entire
world not just Americans it's bad for
the world not just America came from
Stanford and their MBAs they came from
MIT where I studied from you know
supposedly these amazing places where
people are trying to be thoughtful but
once you get to these companies not all
of them but particularly Facebook you're
too focused on how do you get promoted
have you meet all the goals and
expectations that are complete nonsense
that they
set for you but you know that your
income depends on that and ultimately I
think if we are to change the way these
companies run in addition to thinking
about regulation and business models we
also have to think about education and
then creating you know generations of
people who care not only about becoming
rich and famous but who actually deeply
care about building things are actually
positive for the world and the
technology is there you know AI you can
do many things with a label hi thank you
so much for coming I really enjoyed the
talk I'm a student and I'm in a club
called CS Press social good here at
Stanford and I think we're also carrying
on some of the discussions and
conversations that you wish to have yeah
um so my question is more focused on a
subtopic in your book so you argued
about how polarization is intensified on
social media because personal views have
previously been kept intact by social
pressures are not so captain checked on
those digital platforms do you think
Facebook's content moderation efforts is
enough to solve that problem and if you
think they should have more content
moderate moderation how should we weigh
that against the right to free speech
it's a great question so I'm going to
answer the second part first so the
question on moderation is really simple
in my opinion which is remember that I'm
not I'm a free speech person but you
have to distinguish as my partner Renee
de Resta says between freedom of speech
and freedom of reach the issue that
we're dealing with here is I don't want
to restrict what people put on but I
don't want to have a business model that
amplifies asymmetrically the most
negative voices in society and so I
think content moderation is now say a
probability 0.8 or higher can't work at
this scale okay no matter how many
people you put on it the basic notion is
the reason they want content moderation
is they want to gather all that data
they want to get that first pass
reaction from people so they can pierce
the veneer of civility right so
moderation fits the current business
so I would argue that you have to change
the business model if you're really
serious about these problems okay I just
don't I think moderation is the wrong
approach and I just don't think he'll
ever get there and again I'm not a
scientist I can't prove that but I
thought the motherboard massive essay on
that topic and all the cite the journal
stuff I've seen since then makes me
think moderation is not the way okay if
you don't have to - the class will take
just one more there can you give him the
mic you're gonna have to speak much
louder so on the one hand you say that
the core problem here and one of the
core problems is culture
as opposed to like specifically bad
people on the other hand you've kind of
admitted that suck created a culture at
Facebook where criticism and
disagreement pretty much had no place in
which if they had been able to be there
probably we wouldn't be facing these
problems so how do you change culture
without actually being able to call out
bad behavior from the people in charge
if you don't call that out doesn't that
actually create the culture that enables
this that's a great question these are
all amazing questions so the question of
culture specific to company versus the
country as a whole I believe that the
culture of business in the country is
the drive that's the driving thing
Facebook has a specific set of cultural
issues but the culture the thing that
caused Google to go the way it went the
thing that caused mark to believe it was
okay
to build a global footprint to mass this
massive network without any circuit
breakers and without a containment
strategy
those were the result of an external
culture that they just grew up in at
this point in time isn't it isn't it
time now to actually say like hey
whatever the reasons were like this
isn't okay so I'm with you completely
question is is it time to ask for these
leaders like so I can Sandburg to step
down
oh okay so here's what here's what my
problem is changing culture and a
company in short of an of a massive
crisis is almost impossible to do and
only Zuck has the ability to change the
culture at Facebook what I'm praying for
is that he gets a really good night's
sleep and wakes up and has an epiphany
and realizes that he can do a more good
by fixing the culture and business model
of Facebook that he can do with a
thousand Chan Zuckerberg initiative now
I think counting on that is probably not
super realistic but I don't exclude it
okay I mean the mark I knew years and
years ago that wasn't a zero percent are
we kind of past that now we've kind of
been - we may be we may be but keep in
mind my job there's limits to what I can
say in that area
okay I'm not super credible when it
comes to you know the specifics of Mark
I haven't talked to him right you know I
mean I'm out of touch there my gut
instinct though is that if you don't
change the business model it doesn't
matter who runs the company kind of
change the best of all it also doesn't
matter you've been a friend it's like
you're one of the few people who if you
were friends with Zuck you would have
the power to actually be able to tell
him this in a way that he could hear it
but if you can't even tell them this
that's a problem not a problem I agree
with you sorry I'm letting you draw that
conclusion right don't make me keep
saying it out loud okay
I can't be personal between me and them
right that completely destroys my my
platform okay I need to focus on the
ideas right they are my friends I just I
it's not necessary for me to go there to
make the argument I need to make here
and so I totally respect what you've
just said but I'm not gonna engage with
it beyond pointing out that if you don't
fix the business model it literally
doesn't matter who runs it anybody you
put in there with this business model
you're gonna get the same outcome okay
and with that unfortunate gonna sign
some stuff out here if you want to ask
fall off the heater alright thank you
for a great conversation
[Music]
you